um we can now say that the third victim
has been named he is called Ian Coates
and he's a school caretaker from
Nottingham uh let's just cross to our
correspondent up there just to bring us
the very very latest
yes sir Ian Coates a school caretaker
from Nottingham his family saying that
he was in his 60s now this was the man
who was stabbed to death and then his
fan was stolen before it was driven at
three other people one of those people
are in a critical condition in hospital
two others suffered minor injuries and
we know more as well about the two
student victims the two 19 year olds
from Nottingham University one of those
was Barnaby Weber and his parents have
paid tribute to him today David and Emma
and his younger brother Charlie they say
they were so proud of him and they had
been left bereft beyond belief they say
complete Devastation is not enough to
describe our pain and loss at the
senseless murder of our son Barnaby
Phillip John Weber was a beautiful
brilliant bright young man with
everything in life to look forward to as
parents we are enormously proud of every
thing he achieved and all the plans he
made and he was a keen cricketer as well
so the university cricket team and a
local team he played for in Taunton in
Somerset where he was from they've all
played tribute to him as well and are
encouraging people to lay flowers at
that Cricket Club in tribute to him and
the girl who also died she has been
named as Grace Kumar now she was a
talented cricketer and a talented hockey
player as well as she played for the
University but also for her country as
well England Hockey have said we are all
deeply saddened by the news of the
tragic death of Grace Kumar in
Nottingham on Tuesday Grace was a
popular member of the England under 16
and under 18 squads and our thoughts are
with Grace's family friends teammates
and the whole community at this time so
we know a lot more about those two and
the third victim the man who his family
say was in his 60s that is Ian Coates a
school caretaker from Nottingham as
police continue their investigation in
this city trying to find out what the
motive was for this attack they continue
to question a 31 year old suspect on
suspicion of murder